[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
Our today's guest is Evan Snary.
Evan is one of the winners of
the Visualize 2030 contest.
He's a college student
at McMaster University
in Ontario, Canada.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So tell the audience a
little bit about yourself.
What are you busy
with these days?
EVAN SNARY: Yeah, so
right now, I'm currently
attending McMaster University.
But right now I'm on internship,
and at this internship,
I'm using Data Studio
and using visualizations
to present data to our
clients in a meaningful way.
MINHAZ KAZI: How did you
become interested in data
visualization in
the first place?
What got you into it?
EVAN SNARY: Yeah,
so I think it all
started even before
my internship, where
on Reddit, I'd always
follow the subreddit
called Data is
Beautiful, where people
post these visualizations to the
community for them to showcase.
So I think that's really
where it all began
and my interest came from.
MINHAZ KAZI: So you
were interested in data
visualization even before
like you started building vis.
But as you started building
your own visualizations,
how did you get
introduced to Data Studio?
And what has been your
experience with this tool?
EVAN SNARY: Yeah, so to
answer the first question,
I think at my
current internship,
we use Data Studio to
present data to our clients
and provide insights using
this visualization software.
And I think stepping into the
software, that my experience
has been great overall
and its ease of use
really stepped out to me.
It just so easy to use.
And when I first started
on my internship,
I had no experience
with it, but yet, I
could still build these
dashboards for our clientele.
That just shows how easy
it really is to use.
MINHAZ KAZI: You use
Data Studio and you
build a vis for the
Visualize 2030 contest,
and that was actually one of
the winning entries there.
So congrats on that.
EVAN SNARY: Thank you.
MINHAZ KAZI: Maybe you can take
the audience through the vis
and tell them the
story you are trying
to tell throughout
the visualization.
EVAN SNARY: For sure, yeah, if
you want to take a look here.
Yeah, so for my
Visualize 2030 project,
I wanted to focus in on two
of the SDGs of no poverty
and climate action.
So that's what I really focused
on with my interactive vis.
So as you scroll
down, I kind of showed
statistics on what's
happening in the world today
and just bring awareness in
general to what's happening.
And one of the key
findings I found out
that 71% of the total
worldwide emissions
come from these high
income countries.
And we're actually noticing
an increase with middle income
countries, as you can see here.
As they move from low income to
middle income classification,
we're noticing huge
CO2 emission increases
per capita for these nations.
So as you can see, I continued
to add interactive vises
to my Data Studio
project, as I really
wanted to give the audience
a way to interact with it
and find their own
conclusions to the problems.
And here, people are able to
select an individual country
and really dive deeper into,
say, a country of interest,
or if they want to see
just in particular what's
happening in a certain
region of the world,
they're able to see
specifically what's
happening with the
poverty improvement, GDP
growth, and climate
action in these nations.
So I also included
what must be done
and what can we do to
make the problem better.
And I think the key
takeaway for me,
was that we're going
to need to find
a way for these low countries
to develop sustainably,
whether that's through
high income country
aid or worldwide
international funding.
We're going to need to find
a way for these low income
countries to
develop sustainably,
so we don't decrease
poverty, but also
increase climate action
at the same time.
MINHAZ KAZI: What do you
think about Data Studio
as a tool for anyone that's
trying to do data storytelling
and trying to bring
social change?
EVAN SNARY: Yeah, so I
think really we all know
that words only go so far.
And I think providing insights
through graphs or visuals
sometimes provides a better
context on these social change
issues.
So I think Data Studio really
provides an easy and accessible
way for people to use
another platform to reach out
and try to provide change
to these problems we
face in the world today.
MINHAZ KAZI: So
for someone who's
just getting started
with the tool, who's
someone that doesn't have
any experience in building
their own data
visualizations or doesn't
have that much experience
in data storytelling,
how can they get started?
And what tips would
you give them to have
a really compelling story?
EVAN SNARY: Right.
So I think that's
something actually
that my co-workers
always talk about a lot.
And I think the very first
thing is just start simple.
Whether it's one
graph or one bar chart
or one visualization
for that matter,
it really doesn't
matter where you start.
And I think building off that
one visualization is important.
And don't try to do
too much at once.
And really just start simple,
and start with just anything,
really.
MINHAZ KAZI: Evan, thanks
again for being on the show.
You can learn more about
the Visualize 2030 contest
and look at the winning
visualizations from the links
in the description.
For more Data Studio
content, be sure to subscribe
to the ECB channel.
And you can always visit
our site at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
Until next time, keep
building more vis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]